bienvenue ici c'est envergure podcast
dédié aux basketteurs de demain savoir
qui sont ces stars des années prochaine
quel joueur va faire une grande carrière
l autre joueur ne jouera lui jamais en
pro pour savoir ça il faut savoir
évaluer le potentiel le talent la
complémentarité c'est le nerf de la
guerre pour toute équipe pro qui soit de
gagner que l'on parle de basket ball on
pourrait parler d'un autre temps que
c'est la même chose pour en débattre
détailler les mécanismes d'évaluation du
talent on reçoit dans l'épisode de ce
soir
un directeur général general manager
pour les anglophones un directeur de ce
casting est un coach tous en activité
dans le basket français
c'est pour le teesing juste après le
générique épisode vite que 1,4 ces
hangars dur est fait pas
[Musique]
donc il est l'heure de faire les
présentations mais d'abord celui qu'on
ne présente plus tant pour son expertise
sur le pick and roll que pour celles sur
les jeux de mots douteux
romain leroy il supplie plutôt
l'hégémonie que et les invités donc
romain avec nous un casting cinq étoiles
je sais pas jusqu'à dire des toiles des
castings mais cette étoile côté coach
guillaume visa d'entraîneur en chef de
la jeanne d'arc vichy clermont métropole
en pro b
bienvenue guillaume merci bonsoir c'est
de l'art et de patients merci à merci à
toi d'avoir d'avoir répondu à
l'invitation la tradition c'est de
donner le l'envergure
quand on est invité chez envergure de
donner son envergure etienne we are à 92
aa c'est pas mal hein c'est pas mal hein
mais de quatre ans pour quelle taille 1
m 88
ok ok donc une envergure positive tout
va bien côté ce cas outre le boss de
romain en quelque sorte j'ai dit une
bêtise directeur sportif évidemment de
la sig strasbourg en proa donc ou
strasbourg illkirch graffenstaden basket
il est une balle bien mais il va essayer
de parler français il a promis nicolas
alberny benvenuto nicolas comme nicolas
connais-tu tong envergure l'envergure à
m 88 tu as on a dit on a d envergure
très solide
d'accord c'est la même
enfin côté general manager on est ravi
de recevoir le gène du club de blois
l'abeille des aides blois basket j'en ai
appris beaucoup en recherchant les noms
en pro b
julien monclar
bienvenue julien bonsoir à tous merci de
l'invitation tu peux dire à des ah oui
oui bien sûr mais c'était pour l'accueil
de nos auditeurs qu'ils allaient peu
d'envergure julien bahain m 96 mais je
te remettre 97 ce qui fait de moi un
prospect à cet intéressant et celle des
panthères leur héros a une envergure
négative donc ça peut fonctionner pour
ceux qui sont fans du miami heat
messieurs on va on le programme jeux les
données la question à la con et de
répondre ce soir comment il va louer un
joueur un talent on va commencer par qui
qui prend les décisions
en gros à partir du ska août jusqu'au
moment où on signe le joueur comment ça
se passe peut-être que julien tu peux
attaquer là dessus c'est à dire à toi
qui as vers le haut de la chaîne de
décision on va dire quel est le parcours
du joueur que tu vas signer à rentrer
dans ton club
hab an avant que ne soit vraiment
effectif je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
formules valable moi je vais parler à la
demande de ce qu'on pratique nommée mais
on sait que les modèles sont pas les
mêmes
notamment entre entre les états unis et
l'europe et parfois l'europe et la
france
pour ce qui nous concerne dans une
organisation
quand même assez modeste en deuxième
division française en pro b ont fait un
travail de prise de décisions sportives
100% conjointe entre le coach mickaël et
et moi avec
ensuite la signature du président le
président n'interfère pas dans le
recrutement eu juste modalités sur
comme il se doit on va dire mais il n'y
a aucune aucune influence qui est
pratiqué est donc un prêt à tout ce qui
précède et on n'est pas une structure
équipée de deux scouts on a on a bien
sûr un assistant à quelqu'un qui fait
même métier chrome 1 dominique rhône
harkis qui voit beaucoup de matches on
peut demander des avis après sur la sur
les discussions on est on est à deux
têtes et le fait qu'on travaille
ensemble depuis très longtemps
maintenant avec mickaël fait que fait
qu'il n'ya pas besoin d'utiliser le
levier d'un côté ou de l'autre
il va sans dire qu'il sait qu'il décide
pas seul il sait que c'est moi qui
discute avec les agents et a contrario
jamais me viendrait à l'idée avec le
temps de trop pressant ou de lui imposer
un joueur voilà un peu comment ça se
passe chez nous quels sont les avis qui
sont importants pour pour toi quelqu'un
quels sont les tickets key2key qui va
avoir ton oreille en fait pour ce genre
parler de lui l'assistant donc le coach
est ce qu'il ya d'autres personnes qui
gravitent dans le monde du basket à qui
tu vas aller demander des renseignements
j'imagine que oui sur tel ou tel ça
dépend
on si on parle de joueurs internationaux
de ou deux joueurs français sur les
joueurs français en général on sait à
qui on a affaire en termes de coach
d'assistant on va pas j'ai donné un
témoignage l'époque
romain par exemple sur des joueurs en
finlande j'ai apporté pas mal
d'importance à asson à son avis puisque
on a travaillé ensemble à boivent une
époque qui commença à s'éloigner
maintenant c'était la nationale 1 mais à
mais le connaissant en connaissant son
oeil par exemple à l'époque il ya un
joueur que j'avais que j'avais repéré
mais j'en savais pas beaucoup qui avait
pas tout à fait les mêmes moyens et
c'était brandon jefferson et et il
m'avait il y avait deux trois meneurs
très intéressant en finlande sur ces
années là il m'avait parlé de jefferson
en me donnant un témoignage un peu clé
donc on avait vu sa force sur le tir et
c'est le témoignage un peu clé c'était
est maintenu mais parler d'un joueur
club romain qui n'avait pas peur de
prendre ses responsabilités dans la
production monte dans les matches serrés
j'avais regardé quelques matchs à
l'époque
bon il se trouve que il était sous les
radars très tôt dans la saison et puis à
l'intersaison il a très vite été en
dehors de nos de nos possibilités
puisqu'on était un club de n1 qui
voulait monter en pro b et puis à cette
époque là il avait été en slovénie si je
me souviens bien
et ouais et donc c'était au dessus et il
est revenu d'ailleurs en france deux ans
après mais il est venu en relayant dans
une grosse écurie pro b ce que nous on
était pas mais donc par exemple j'aime
bien connaître les gens avaient ce pas
que j'apporte pas d'importance de la vie
de quelqu'un d'un coach ou dans
l'assistant mais si on ne connaît pas
c'est très difficile l'oeil de chacun et
pas et pas le même et surtout il ya le
mot le mot clé celui qui revient
beaucoup dans la bouche de mon coach on
connaît personne qui se dit pas exigeant
tout le monde est exigeant mais quel
degré d'exigence et sur quels points
voilà donc mentalement
quand on secoue ton on doit remonter des
faits et prendre le moins de parti
possible
après on sait que ces impositions c'est
qu'on peut pas être objectif et
l'objectivité n'existe pas réellement
et c'est pour ça que que c'est assez
compliqué j'ai moi j'ai besoin d'avoir
vraiment une relation assez forte avec
quelqu'un pour l'écouté de manière de
manière durable on va dire les agents
bien évidemment peuvent avoir un mot à
dire parce qu'ils sont ils sont présents
dans ce dans ce business à notre niveau
mais mais avec des filtres énorme et
davantage c'est dur on les connaît un
plus on peut placer le filtre oui
absolument
on va rester dans un club de même la
même division guillaume est ce que toi
aussi tu participes à la décision de le
recruter tel ou tel joueur est même
question à quoi tu va accorder de
l'importance
combien de matchs tu vas regardé en
moyenne je sais que c'est difficile à
quantifier mais quand tu veux recruter
un joueur qui va avoir son oreille pour
répondre d'avoir sur le début de la
question sur l'organisation
je suis assez central dans
l'organisation du recrutement puisque
j'ai pas de on va dire de manager
général qui fait le lien avec les agents
et la partie négociations donc cette
partie là c'est moi qu'ils l'assument
donc en fait on construit le scouting
avec mon assistant avec jonathan
jonathan ne boucle qui a un rôle
consultatif là dessus on travaille toute
l'année là dessus puis ensuite moi je
vais sélectionner des profils qui
correspondent à l'identité qu'on veut
donner à l'équipe et je vais les
présenter à david melody qui est notre
directeur exécutif qui est un ancien
joueur de de pro à qui un régional aussi
comme comme moi du club et ensuite on va
on va avancer vers la prise de décisions
ensemble sur la finalité
par contre la partie négociations c'est
moi qui vais l'assumer pour le club
donc quand on est dans cette période là
on va dire c'est plus facile
à partir du moment où on est d'à
corps de mener il ya moins
d'interlocuteurs par contre la surcharge
de travail avait quand même assez
importante pour moi sur l'intersaison
et quand on passe sur le côté évaluation
de joueurs donc la deuxième partie de ta
question là dessus on va être sur trois
quatre matches complets peut-être mais
ils vont être largement étayée
parlez-nous par les outils de scouting
que peuvent être in stat que peuvent
être synergies et les complémentarités
de statistiques avancées comme sur ibm
etc
et c'est vrai que in stat notamment
qu'on à la disposition nous par exemple
club
ça permet un tri sélectif sur des
données particulières du jeu typo de
type g recruter un meneur de jeu cette
année qui était en lettonie estonie et
ça m'a permis de décortiquer vraiment
quasiment toutes les situations de pick
and roll qui avait été référencées
durant son année donc ça faisait quelque
chose comme comme 300-400 clip de pick
and roll et finalement c'était le même
temps que de regarder un match et demi
de match mais sauf que sur le qualitatif
on était complètement sur une donnée clé
pour moi c'est ça permettait de rentrer
en détail sur sur une compétence du
joueur mais des outils in stat je
connais pas mais c'est à peu près la
même chose que synergis de vue oui avec
une interface on va dire qui a été
acquis un peu plus convivial nicolas on
va passer du côté de strasbourg avec un
club avec un peu plus de moyens qui voit
les joueurs qui sont recrutés par la sig
est ce que vous faites appel à des
personnes sur le terrain qui sont ils
comment travaille-t-il et toi qu'est le
poids tu as dans la prise de décision
qui tue à consulter avant de prendre une
décision de recrutement a normalement je
travaille comme ça je fais ce casting
tous l'année et je regarde beaucoup
beaucoup de mettre moi-même et j'ai
je prépare une liste idéale des joueurs
qui sont peut-être quelque chose comme
60 70 joueurs pour le printemps et sur
les joueurs que sur les meilleurs pour
l'idée du club pour l'idée de
l'entraîneur pour l'aider pour la
possibilité du budget et avant tous pour
m'a aidée de basket que se baser sur une
grande dureté mentale est intangible
après ça je travaille beaucoup sur tous
sur chercher des informations fausses
sur la personnalité surtout tout ce
qu'on peut pas avoir deux sur les sur
les vidéos et ça c'est le travail des
dix mois et après quand quand même
printers april march mais je vais
présenter au coach le mieux
gilles je n'aime pas que les coaches et
il doit faire beaucoup beaucoup de
travail
normalement ces deux trois normes par
position et et jeu j'aime que les
coaches et ils sachent qu'ils pour voir
les derniers votes dans un un commando
d'environ 2 3 joueurs tout un jeu j'aime
travailler comme ça car pour les coaches
il faut qu'ils pensent aller elle est
présente mais je travaille pour le futur
pourtant que tu veux pas faire les deux
jobs est mon travail c
présenter des jeux qu'il ne connaît pas
elle ne peut pas connaître car je
travaille sur ça chaque jour ça c'est
mon délit diop des parcs avec maurice
kalt de deux directeurs sportifs des
autres entraîneurs germain je dirais que
le monde va nous mener
et après j'aime beaucoup aussi que les
assistant coach se connecter avec nous
car j je voudrais que si s'il ya des
problèmes avec deux jours tout le monde
il sache avant qu'on va prendre deux
semaines rcc pibor c'est ce niveau qu'il
peut pas jouer les seconds rôles ce
monarque et leurs petits pots de tunnel
vision
il faut que tout le monde sache avant tu
pour te faire mon travail pour moi mais
pour moi je n'aime pas étudié beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup les joueurs comment
ils font
beaucoup de scal je suis pas au cas où
tu pues risque à août pour moi les plus
intéressantes j'ai regardé les contextes
de les joueurs ça c'est le flou fera
mais mon vrai travail est de créer un
discours avec l'entraîneur pour père
comment comment ces joueurs ça marche ça
marche pas ou pourquoi la saison passée
il a joué mieux
lagier pire c'est la clé pour moi c'est
la clé de tous très intéressants on
reviendra plus tard sur les notions que
vous avez abordé tous les trois un peu
de complémentarité avec avec l'équipe 2
est évidemment des critères qu'on
utilise pour recruter un joueur
simplement à mon romain sûr là on parle
de cette rupture
les évidemment les franchises de nba
puisque nous on parle souvent de la
draft dans le podcast elles ont encore
plus de moyens que ça c'est à dire qu'il
ya des salons peut expliquer rapidement
c'est un réseau de ce cas où tu qui vont
rapporter des informations sur le com
dit comme disait nicolas d'aider des
enfants sur les hinton giebel sur voilà
le mental de tel ou tel joueur son
attitude son environnement personnel à
un directeur et qui ensuite va faire
remonter aux ogm cas l'addition finale
je suis une espèce de système pyramidal
or chaque chaque franchisé construite un
petit peu différemment c'est la
discussion que j'ai eue hier avec avec
un journaliste de l'ats de la nouvelle
république de l'édition de loi que
m'avait qui avaient été orientés sur sur
mon numéro de téléphone par par julien
où je vais expliquer en fait donc le
système cardiaque n'est pas le même bac
seulement partout mais toutes les
franchises ont des scouts en europe et
toutes les franchises en plus des scouts
ont des consultants dans certains pays
donc c'est un travail de fourmi et qui
est pas forcément toujours axé sur
basket comme dirait nicolas le
l'histoire du contexte est très
importante et le basket c'est quelque
chose qui est parfois on va dire entre
guillemets simple à évaluer ce qui l'est
beaucoup moins c'est la personnalité du
joueur c'est la complémentarité qui peut
avoir avec tel ou tel profil c'est
pourquoi dans tel contexte
va être peut-être plus efficace que l'on
tel autre et ainsi de suite elle sait
plus sur cette partie là que les
franchises biais charge vraiment à
gratter notamment par le biais des
consultants et des du réseau de coach
qui peut avoir dans certains pays pour
avoir des infos on va dire plus que
précisé qu'ils seraient pas forcément
les choses qu'on regardera en premier
juste dans le cas d'une construction d'
équipes simple en fait guillaume tu
parlais tout à l'heure des outils de
stats avancé pour pour effectuer un gros
tri au niveau du recrutement
maintenant quand il faut choisir quels
critères objectifs on alors d'un
recrutement tu parlé d'attitude sur le
pick and roll est ce que vraiment on
adapte le recrutement au besoin où est
ce qu'on va privilégier le maximum de
talent qu'on peut avoir avec bien sûr
les le cadre salarial ajusté je pense
qu'à une question d' équilibre que tout
le monde essaye d'avoir entre entre le
talent et le fitr qui est réglée par le
par le financier très très souvent mais
la prise de décision elle se fait
beaucoup sur l'humain au final c'est à
dire que quand on a un triller qu'on
arrive à on va dire à finaliser sur deux
trois choix on va chercher de l'unetel
sur deux des renseignements sur les sur
les personnalités et finalement on
décide quel type de personnalité pour
quel type de talent et c'est peut-être
là où on fait la part des choses et on
essaie de créer un équilibre de l'équipe
autour de ça même si on est sur une
hypothèse est que cette hypothèse là on
pourra la valider qu'une fois que les
gens seront ensemble puisque tant qu'ils
sont pas ensemble on peut pas connaître
la véritable personnalité profonde
puisque la personnalité elle change
aussi en fonction de l'environnement du
contexte dans lequel on met les joueurs
c'est pour ça que va dire si ce fut
peut-être un peu là le distinguo entre
les joueurs français les jeunes joueurs
français et les joueurs étrangers
j'essaye d'avoir des joueurs étrangers
qui ont été dans des conditions où il
s'est déjà le job pour lesquels on va
essayer de les employer
si par exemple un meneur de jeu
titulaire et c'est un leader d'équipé
cetera et d'un côté on va
peut-être chercher un peu plus de
outside un petit peu plus de potentiel
chez d'autres typologie du joueur ou là
on va essayer de créer un rôle évolutif
en leur laissant une place et en
espérant que le joueur qu'on recrute au
mois d'août quand on arrive au mois de
janvier février ben ça sera plus le même
joueur
et finalement on se rend compte que
c'est ces joueurs là qui apporte une
plus value à l'équipe et qui font que
vous passer du statut de bad une équipe
peut-être moyenne vis-à-vis de vos
moyens et c'est à une équipe qui peut
performer et qui peuvent peut-être jouer
les trouble fête dans votre niveau de
performance julien est ce que cette
notion de complémentarité et j'imagine
qu'elle existe aussi dans ta vision des
choses
on parlait je ne sais plus lors de
quelques tests on parlait de il ya
besoin d'un méchant dans une équipe où
il ya besoin voilà il ya tout un tas de
théories comme celle ci est ce que tu en
a vraiment qui sont tous contents gym
qui sont uniques qui sont des principes
que tu as dans dans la plaie le premier
principe qu'on a ça va à peu rejoint ce
que décrit guillaume c'est dans la
finalisation puisqu'on arrive toujours
tout ça des short list si on part sur le
sujet précédente
donc je on cible nos toujours à l'avant
sa longueur d'année on a l'état de nos
on va dire nos contrats et ça nous
permet de positionner les postes sur
lesquels on sait qu'on sera
si on parle avec un vocable un peu plus
anglophone entre guimaëc des agents
libres ou des free agency c'est pas le
bon bout mais on sait moi je sais déjà
sur quels postes on va rechercher sur
l'année suivante
donc on fait nos listes après on arrive
à des ad des finalistes en général et là
on rentre dans la phase
on fonctionne de plus en plus avec
michael sur de l'entretien et on a
tendance à être assez peu dans la
séduction au final et à noircir le
tableau
parce que parce que avant même de parler
de contexte et de complémentarité je
pense que la cour la première
complémentarité c'est entre le joueur et
le clama c'est ce qu'on lui propose et
il en phase avec ses attentes
parce que quand on le joueur se trompe
dans le choix du club à cause d'attentes
mal dimensionné pour moi elle s'est déjà
un échec ça ne pourra pas fonctionner et
donc la première des choses c'est
s'assurer que ce qu'on va lui proposer
en termes de contexte en termes de
conditions de travail de volume de
travail et de projection dans le jeu
même si là dessus c'est la limite là
qu'on est le plus réservé parce que hong
hao fonctionne assez peu au statut dans
dans notre club et ça c'est la première
des choses donc la première
complémentarité est les joueurs club
après il ya la complémentarité du groupe
et bien sûr qu'on va rechercher les
trois que les trois grands critères que
je mettrais c'est donc sur l'humain
l'aspect alors méchant le cliché du
méchant c'est je pense que c'est un
petit peu moins vrai qu'à une époque
mais mais malheureusement d'en haut
niveau il ya souvent le talent versus
l'agressivité que je mettrais quand même
c'est c'est rarement les joueurs qui ont
vraiment les deux en général peuvent
aller très loin
les problématiques de mobilité puisque
la vitesse est un facteur la vitesse est
cependant bien sûr de notamment de
vitesse latéral et parle pas évidemment
de vitesse de course strictement même si
ça reste un facteur important donc sur
la mobilité et la vitesse on a vraiment
si jamais on a une faiblesse sur un
poste on va vraiment cherché à la
compenser par
par la rotation par les postes
environnants et au final depuis quelques
années de plus en plus on est sur un
basket of positionne donc la
complémentarité elle est plus dans les
profils que dans les positions on aime
bien aussi avoir des garçons qui peuvent
glisser qui peuvent jouer ensemble
chez nous on est capable de jouer de
manière très régulière avec trois
joueurs extérieurs d'un mètre 90 environ
on a aussi pas vraiment de ma part on a
un poste 4 qui est notre joueur le plus
référencé le notre meilleur joueur
thaïlande johnson qui est mvp du
championnat entre guillemets à deux
reprises mais sur les autres joueurs du
secteur en taille peuvent jouer
indifféremment sur les deux passé
quelque chose qu'on recherche depuis
plusieurs saisons maintenant donc
donc voilà donc la complémentarité à se
décrète pas mais elle s'ajuste au fur et
à mesure de l'avancement de la
construction d'effectifs
nicolas tu parlais tout à l'heure de de
thé recrutement par rapport à différents
critères est ce que tu t'es déjà trompé
est-ce qu'il ya déjà eu des erreurs à
cause justement de la complémentarité
qu'est ce que ça a pu apprendre ce genre
d'erreurs s'il y en a eu des erreurs
dans ma carrière
oui bien sûr tout comme il ya tout
devient mieux après les erreurs pourtant
j'ai fait beaucoup d'erreurs
et ça c'était clair que m'a donné
beaucoup d'expérience je pense qu'avant
tous il faut chercher
il faut avoir une idée pour la pour
l'équipe
g j'ai compris avec l'expérience qui il
faut avoir
je n'aime pas ou beaucoup d'origine où
il faut avoir une idée je n'aime pas les
équipes généralistes je n'aime pas juste
les chercheurs les meilleures manières
pour nous les meilleurs shooting guard
les meilleurs postes 4 saint venant
je pense qu'à ce bel pour faire ça mais
tous les autres ce serait mieux si on
cherche d'avoir une identité
particulière actions vont être comme
pour les implants dentaires qu'ils
aiment basket très vite et beaucoup de
tirs de trois points ça c'est une idée
il joue avec une idée on n'a plus une
identité claire et sa tête va taïder
pour avoir quelque chose en plus et pour
avoir dîné dans l'équipe donne
et tout va mettre les joueurs dans cette
idée ça c'est la première chose je fais
des erreurs tout c'est la
complémentarité peut être des baskets
mais même des personnes âgées ou quand
j'ai eu pour origine peut-être la
dernière saison aaron je n'avais pas
beaucoup d'argent et j'ai fait une
équipe très jeune et juste de potentiel
mais quand tu es mais je vais débourou
qui j'ai joué cette année
jordan morgan melvin et jim de bons
joueurs mais conditionne trop john trap
ensemble le problème c'est que dans
abidjan des quelques quelqu'un qui a de
l'expérience
pas beaucoup de talent mais quand on va
chercher juste les potentiels tout va ça
sert d'être meilleur que les autres
après il va pas être chauvin et j'aurais
mauvaise météo
les bons joueurs très chers elle venait
aussi mais tous ensemble c'est pas bien
pourtant il faut penser ça semble être
un exemple très clair pour moi il faut
chercher auquel la complémentarité sur
le terrain'' même même la comparabilité
la complémentarité sur les macarons
d'avoir prêté pour tous julien je vais
poser la même question sur les
éventuelles erreurs que tu as pu faire
est ce que tu as pu en retirer en
maintenant matière de recrutement je
trouve ça intéressant de partir de ça
pour savoir ce que c'est à sa [ __ ] à
prendre sur alors ça peut être des
erreurs de complémentarité ou d'autres
choses dans ce
toute façon en l'erreur elle existe
ponctuel mais c'est ce que vient de dire
nicolas la principale erreur c'est une
erreur quand on se fourvoie dans son
identité
nous on en a fait et je vais vous donner
un exemple cette ville est assez facile
à comprendre la trajectoire du club ça a
été d'avoir justement une identité
autour de l'effort du partage du ballon
du partage des responsabilités et une
construction d'une hiérarchie scène
depuis quasiment depuis huit saisons à
blois donc ça nous a permis de gagner la
nationale 1 puis 2 d'avoir maintien très
confortable en pro b la première année
d'autres champions de france de pro b la
deuxième année et de subir un bras ce
qui est quoi qu'il advienne une
expérience difficile sert de ne pas
recevoir le du sportif qui qui était le
nôtre donc ce qu'on n'avait pas on
n'avait pas été acceptée en jeep élite
pour des raisons de timing de centre de
formation
voilà c'est pas le sujet
cette année là c'était très difficile
l'intersaison puisqu'on a passé deux
mois pas savoir dans quelle division
d'aller jouer
moi j'avais de recrutement en permanence
la tête partout à garder des dégâts sous
feu pour la pro b à voir des gens qui
appellent en cas de dix pays étaient
d'autant qu'un problème et moi des choix
à faire donc c'était très compliqué tout
un environnement club pour partie en
décrochage et et donc on a on a fait
notre équipe on est en revanche à en se
disant moi j'ai compris qu'on ira en pro
b à ses taux par rapport à d'autres
personnes dans le club
j'ai fait mon deuil de la jeep et on est
parti sur la construction d'une équipe
pro b on avait déjà pas pu la faire
comme on le souhaitait à cause du ce
contexte là et donc on a voulu faire une
équipe en étant revanchard on a vu une
dynamique budgétaire pas inintéressante
pour la pro b puisque on avait gagné on
a vu une nouvelle salle donc on avait un
peu plus d'argent et on a on a fait deux
choses c'est qu'on a eu tendance à
vouloir prendre le meilleur joueur sur
son poste noëlla bourreau qui sortait
d'une très belle saison avec fos sur mer
qui est qui nous semblait apporter un
impact physique très fort on a gardé
taille rennes qui était une vie du du
championnat et on a fait un choix qu'on
n'aurait jamais imaginé faire qui était
celui de joe barton qui est un joueur
avec un immense talent un physique très
atypique poste 5
assez petit et ben qui pèse très très
lourd vraiment très très gros gabarit un
talent offensif assez important et n'est
pas dans nos valeurs défensives dans la
production des forts et notamment
notamment sur la mobilité dont je
parlais mais il y avait aussi l'envi le
coach sortez d'une saison des situations
tellement frustrante
il avait gagné et quand il m'a dit que
le seul bémol de l'équipe de l'année
précédente c'était peut-être le talent
offensif sur le post sur le poste 5
qu'on avait eu du mal quand on avait
quand on avait besoin de scoring sur ce
poste là et ça lui faisait envie de voir
s'ils pouvaient peut-être changer un
joueur comme ça et on ya cru moi aussi
j'ai cru
on fait tous les choix conjointement on
s'est dit allez on va voir si un joueur
comme ça on peut en faire quelque chose
de différent et donc on n'a pas réussi
on a eu une cohésion d'équipé
défaillante cette année là on a quand
même gagné 19 matchs ce qui est plutôt
très bien mais on est passé par des
moments très difficiles et et on a on a
vraiment compris cette saison là qu'on
s'était fourvoyé dans notre manière de
faire et on a pu redresser le la barre
la saison suivante qui était la saison
19 ans on a fait une équipe qui nous
ressemblait énormément avec une énorme
cohésion hors terrain et ça on l'avait
et vous lui en amont avec des jeunes des
anciens des gens qui avaient une
histoire commune et ça avait porté ses
fruits et chacun a trouvé son rôle donc
c'est vrai qu'on a eu un contraste hyper
fort entre la saison 18 19 et 19 ans qui
illustre très bien les erreurs qu'on
peut faire et la chance qu'on a eue de
réussir à réagir aux médias quand je
vous entends les uns les autres j'ai
quand même l'impression qu'on pour la
majorité des recrutements on va pas le
talent et n'arrive pas en premier sur la
liste des priorités ce que je me trompe
guillaume parce qu en terme de talent
déjà on choisit des joueurs qui sont
soit sur la pro b en termes d'étapes où
je passe pour la pro b avec julien et
moi par exemple ou si on devait choisir
par le talent ces joueurs là est souvent
ils vont plus vers le vers l'étape du
dessus peut-être la jeep et des
européens notamment pour les joueurs
étrangers
et en parlant de mauvaises expériences -
vis-à-vis du talent un jour j'ai fait ce
choix là sur un joueur dominicain gérard
d'hossus hérault où on a fait vraiment
le choix du talent de dire on prend le
risque et moi j'avais eu des quelques
retours peut-être qui aurait pu
entraîner quelques réticences mais et ça
vaut le coup et c'est vrai que ce basket
mans parlant ça va les coûts sur le fait
que ben ce joueur post 2 avait un talent
énorme
il dominait la ligue république la
dominique en terme de scoring sa vidéo
retours positifs de de ricardo notamment
ricardo greer qu'il avait eu avec
l'équipe nationale mais il s'est trouvé
que ce joueur des racines et de son
contexte
lui qui n'était jamais venu en europe il
a eu toutes les difficultés du monde à
s'intégrer plus tôt dans la vie sociale
dans la vie locale dans dans le dans la
typologie de jeu et même s'ils
produisaient des points il n'était pas
épanoui n'étais pas heureux et de son
propre chef à noël il a demandé à
rentrer et donc là le fit il était c'est
presque humainement ce ciel manquent eux
on n'a pas les deux points et finalement
peut-être que dans le recrutement
aujourd'hui je suis un peu plus
sensibles à ça notamment sur ses
projections la notamment dans les
discussions avec le joueur pour
appréhender cette situation avec avec
plus de facilité ça passe par ce que
décrivait julien tout à l'heure
quasiment des entretiens d'embauché
comme ce qui est d'ailleurs pratique est
de plus en plus et qui va avoir des
plans plus d'importance cette année pour
ceux qui sont abonnés je peux conseiller
un article 2 10 athlétique qui parle de
fonctionnement pour les franchises nba
du scouting cette année qui va être
extrêmement difficile puisque les scot
n'ont pas le droit d'aller voir les
matchs en tout cas les matchs
universitaires donc c'est très très
compliqué et donc ils vont accorder
encore plus d'importance à aline
interview nicolas est ce que c'est ton
cas aussi tu parlais de dureté mentale
d'alleurs tu disais le basket ball c'est
un sport moi je considère qu'il faut
être dur mentalement comment tu évalues
ça le plus difficile je pense car vous
avez parlé dès le 30 mai
il est à l'aise je pense que c'est le
plus facile d'acheter sur le match on a
beaucoup de talent mais si vous regardez
les équipes souvent ils vont à confirmer
ils vont à mettre l'argent sous les
joueurs qu'ils ont que sont leurs aînés
ils vont à réfléchir l'identité du club
sur le terrain après les joueurs qu'il
faut prendre pour chuter 15 fois pour
permettre ça c'est toujours valable dans
le marché ça c'est mon idée au moins
pour évaluer leur dureté du joueur
jeumont mais toutes ces déchets chercher
des informations de les jeunes qui j'ai
confiance
dès mon ami de l'escoute que je crois
elle comprend une bonne idée du basket
les entraîneurs les directeurs sportifs
qu'ils ont la même vision que moi mais
c'est très difficile
je n'aime pas appeler tout le monde
c'est pour chercher des informations sur
juin car je ne sais pas la vision l'idée
les asus hérité de la personne au
téléphone je ne connais pas pourtant tu
contre étonné network tout fait
confiance sur le net et il faut que les
maires pour ses programmes après tout
pour avoir cette qualité des formations
d'une formation très difficile julien
comment est-ce que tu as cette même idée
de dureté mentale et comment comment
l'évaluer aussi si on rentre dans le
détail de du processus d'interview que
tu décris vais tout à l'heure est ce que
tu vas essayer
qu'est ce que tu as essayé de chercher à
comprendre chez chers joueurs à savoir
quelle question va lui donner c'est
difficile parce qu'on rentre dans un
quelque chose d'assez psychologique
puisque il ya des joueurs qui sont
capables de très bons en entretien et
avec l'expérience on arrive à détecter
ceux qui savent dire ce qu'on a envie
d'entendre
jouant pour autant le sentir au plus
profond d'eux après c'est clairement il
ya de l'instant dans tout ça et qu on
recoupe bien sûr est que toutes les
images qu'on voit la dureté mentale et
je trouve le sujet intéressant alors
nous on a une spécificité aussi c'est
que c'est qu'aujourd'hui on joue avec
avec on a un groupe de 11 joueurs il ya
qu un étranger et on le connaît très
bien puisqu'il puis longtemps donc on va
dire que quand on a évalué un joueur
domestique
on a quand même on a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup d'éléments on a quand même
beaucoup d'éléments et derrière
l'entretien peut fonctionner il suffit
de deux poids piégé surprendre à la
réaction n'ont pas de choix
c'est même pas un entretien c'est une
discussion le mot c'est pas entretien
c'est vraiment discussions le mot clé
c'est mettre à l'aise pour aller
chercher la la sincérité chez la
personne et puis et puis voir dans
quelle mesure on est capable d'avancer
ensemble
donc au final pour nous c'est pas
forcément le sujet le plus compliqué je
conçois tout à fait que ça le soit pour
canton quand on secoue temps un volume
de joueurs notamment des étrangers gers
une source
les us est une source intarissable de
joueur donc
donc là là l'information est plus dur à
capter nous c'est les joueurs de
mystique c'est plus simple pour notre
part le la question la plus difficile à
analyser c'est la compréhension du jeu
parce que c'est le cerveau c'est là
c'est la capacité à absorber les
informations parce qu'on a un entraîneur
qui demande beaucoup sur ce plan là avec
un simple et voilà il ya ennahda
playbook pardon un playbook archi très
dense on va dire guillaume peut en
témoigner et donc ça là il ya des
attentes avec beaucoup de lecture une
capacité à faire des choix
à regarder avant la prise de balle pour
effectuer un choix d'air et ça
honnêtement je trouve que je trouve
qu'en vidéo c'est le plus dur à analyser
parce que c'est beaucoup plus difficile
à analyser que la capacité à faire à
faire une différence a gagné un contre
un mais deux des tirs ou à prendre des
rebonds
c'est cette capacité à faire des choix
et à prendre des décisions dans un
contexte d'opposition et dans un
contexte d'un basket assez assez avancé
on va dire et c'est là que c'est là que
on peut on peut faire des paris parfois
gagnant parfois parfois perdant et c'est
vrai que c'est le point sur lequel moi
je cherche
cette année là encore des clés pour
essayer d'identifier d'identifier les
joueurs qui ont cette cette force-là
parce qu'en général on sait qu'avec eux
on pourra faire de bonnes choses
guillaume la prise de décision c'est
quelque chose d'intéressant c'est
quelque chose qu'on cite souvent aussi
sur le le podcast comme un pré requis
pour être un joueur efficace à haut
niveau et pas pénalisant pour son équipe
que ce soit offensivement défensivement
est ce que toi aussi tu accorde
énormément d'importance à ça parce que
justement c'est difficile à évaluer ce
qu'il ya autre chose dont vous parlez de
dureté mentale on parlait de deux salles
de leyme de la capacité à comprendre le
jeu ce qui est un autre critère qui toi
est très important celui-là il est
central pour moi parce que je pense que
c'est pour celui là que j'entraîne c'est
ma c'est un petit peu ma raison d'être
au moteur j'essaye toujours de de
développer ça chez les joueurs autant
autant que je peux dans un jeu ouvert
avec beaucoup de possibilités et où on
est porté pour la bande à anjou un tempo
assez soutenue avec des prises de
risques des prises de responsabilité et
donc ça le support beaucoup d'importance
oui et si on devait trouver un autre un
autre critère c'est peut-être cette idée
de polyvalence julien il le souligner
tout à l'heure dans notre dans notre
basket de pro b
il ya peut-être un critère de
nivellement sur les tailles sur les
profils tout le monde est un petit peu
under size et du coup on est obligé
d'avoir des joueurs qui ont une
polyvalence et une complémentarité assez
importante et plus les plus les on va
dire les côtes se renouvelle dans la
division puis on sent que c'est
c'est une tendance forte dans le jeu et
que pour trouver des nouvelles armes et
des nouveaux outils à exploiter dans le
jeu collectif
c'est une nécessité d'avoir d'avoir
cette polyvalence chez laisser les
joueurs pour amener c'est pas moi des
joueurs extérieurs à poster ou peut-être
des joueurs extérieurs à jouer sur des
positions de deux postes 4 pour ouvrir
d'autres possibilités sur certaines
séquences en inversion en inversant les
postes etc
ça donne une richesse et de la
profondeur au jeu et ça on essaye je
pense de plus en plus quand on quand on
liste les joueurs de se dire bon voilà
ce joueur l'âge des embauches pour ça il
sait le faire
il a ce métier là et en même temps quand
j'observe je sens qu'il ya aussi une
notion de potentialités et qu'à une
notion ou si je veut l'amener ailleurs
si je veux développer peut-être son
mindset et peut-être l'amener à franchir
des étapes dans sa carrière peut-être
qu'il ya des perspectives aussi à à lui
à l'ouvrir vers d'autres choses à
l'intérieur du jeu donc toute façon
c'est un peu un mouvement global cette
histoire de polyvalence que qu'elles
soient offensifs comme tu décrivait ou
ou défensives
justement est ce qu'il ya une situation
de jeu en particulier où toi tu vas te
dire ce joueur là il peut être
polyvalent c'est à dire que quand tu va
regarder les matchs d'un joueur ou le
joueur sur synergie ou in stat est ce
que tu veux tu vas chercher en
particulier justement les situations de
jeu qui arrive est fréquemment mais sur
lesquelles il serait efficace
on parlait tout à l'heure de la
profondeur du nombre de joueurs
américains et une qualité qui peut être
difficile à évaluer chez les meneurs de
chemin et qui en europe notamment dans
les ligues mineures scellé leur capacité
à jouer sans le ballon parce que très
souvent ils sont dans des ligues où il
porte le ballon peut-être de manière
excessive parfois et
si on veut aller vers un jeu avec de la
polyvalence ou avec jouer et affronter
des équipes qui vont avoir un scouting
aboutis où il va falloir faire jouer le
joueur dans d'autres situations
moi ce qui m'a 20 ce qui va m'intéresser
c'est par exemple de d'observer si le
mna de jeu il est capable de jouer
autour d'écrans d'en porter qu'il est
capable de jouer autour de situations de
backdoor s'il est capable de jouer sur
sur d'autres situations que simplement
porter la balle jouer autour du pick and
roll donc ça ça peut nous intéresser
et de la même manière défensivement il
ya des situations qu'on switch par
exemple entre petits et grands sur dans
notre volonté défensive et ça va nous
intéresser par exemple savoir si le
joueur pendant une deux trois secondes
il est capable de résister à un rôle
d'un joueur intérieur est ce qui peut
batailler ce qui peut passer devant
c'était pas la compétence clé défensif
qu'on va observer
par contre quand on va aller plus loin
dans l'évaluation du profil ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on va observer et je
rejoins un petit peu ce que disait
nicolas tout à l'heure on va pouvoir
observer aussi sa dureté mentale quand
il est dans des zones un petit peu hors
de ses ors de ses points forts par
exemple un suisse défensive l'honneur
avec un joueur intérieur ça peut
peut-être ça arrive parfois et bien est
ce qu'il est capable de passer devant de
lutte et de combattre s'il ya un
mismatch au rebond est ce qu'il est
capable d'avoir la dureté nice esther
durant une de seconde pour quand même se
sauver de cette situation et gagner le
ballon ça c'est des observable qui
rejoignent un peu les intangible un
petit peu la dureté mentale et quand on
va en profondeur dans les matchs je
pense que c'est appréciable d'aller
chercher ce type de détails
nicolas est ce que tu tu rejoins julien
et et guillaume sur le côté polyvalence
l'importance de la polyvalence dans le
basket-ball moderne
est-ce que c'est aussi quelque chose que
tu recherches et comment tu va l'évaluer
tu as beaucoup parlé du mental mais ce
peu lorsque tu va regarder des matches
il ya des situations particulières que
tu vas auquel tu as porté plus
d'attention
une clé pour le basket moderne et j'aime
beaucoup les joueurs qu'ils pouvaient
jouer à d'autres 2 3 positions au
minimum et dans la même équipe de les
joueurs qu'il faut vingt joueurs à
ensemble dans les mêmes rôles pour
exemple j'aime beaucoup à voir domenech
qu'ils peuvent ils peuvent jouer en
simple les deux post 4 qu'elle pourrait
joueurs ensemble les 2.5 il pouvait
jouer un simple ça c'est complet d'une
de post 3 ça c'est très important que le
proviseur ensemble sasson clé d'une
équipe pas moderne gps in italy nous
sommes nos habitudes c'est des joueurs
très petit et plus petit qu en france
mais les mineurs les minimes honneur
c'est quelque chose de basket français
nous avons pas beaucoup les petits
mineurs même si un strasbourg nous avons
un très bon mais c'est quelque chose que
c'est très important car personnellement
j'aime beaucoup je pense que rooney non
c'est parce que j'aime beaucoup je pense
que c'est nécessaire
prince sert à avoir une équipe qu'il
faut dans les deux dernières deux trois
minutes au toucher gère avec en cinq
cantons pouvoir dans les deux derniers
plus de trois minutes
ça ça c'est vraiment on a entendu un
grand cadeau pour les coaches car c'est
très simple pour lui et c'était
difficile pour les opposants pour
l'adversaire des recherches de créer des
avantages
pourtant ça c'est un pur miracle
vraiment vraiment sûr qu'un chercheur de
construire une équipe que pour jouer
avec beaucoup beaucoup de face dans la m
la même identité besoin pour nous avons
gagné à cholet dans la coupe de france
avec une starting five les joueurs les
pelouses autre roman c'était combien en
mètre 95
peut-être mais ok nous allons de juin
blessé mais ça c'est notre seule notre
d'éditer possession c'est ce que dit
nicolas sont fait la réflexion avec avec
la cie et et franck l'a surtout les
débuts de matches à chaque fois on se
regarde rosimond encore l'équipe la plus
petite sur le terrain cirque on pourrait
jouer je pense qu'on joue des équipes de
pro b demain on est peut-être même plus
petit que certains certaines équipes de
pro b globalement sur le sur
l'entre-deux au départ et ça ne pose pas
de problème ou ça en pause certains mais
comme tu dis ça se retrouve dans la
statuaire l2 sur l'idée du mismatch tout
ce que tu vas perdre d'un côté tu leur
as l'autre ce qu'on va peut-être perdre
en taille on a beau être une équipe
aujourd'hui nous a à strasbourg qui est
plus petit
à l'heure actuelle je fais un pointage
régulièrement au niveau des stades que
je suis beaucoup c'est tout ce qui est
travail au rebond
on a une efficacité aujourd'hui au
rebond qui comment dire qui est presque
antinomique à proprement parler quand on
regarde le fait qu'on fait une petite
équipe on est des équipes les plus
efficaces du championnat au rebond par
exemple alors ça veut dire agressivité
sévir mobilité le si le rebond était
uniquement résumé avec la taille et la
densité physique ça se saurait d'autres
critères puis dennis rodman n'aura
jamais eu la carrière qu'il a eue si non
mais non voilà sait où on va on va voir
la mobilité défensive au revoir la
mobilité offensive on va on va pouvoir
faire connaître un peu plus de choses en
défense que si on était plus grand et
plus haut quand on a joué diminue son
père à la maison mais c'est plus grand
que moi tous les postes par exemple
peristeri c'est plus grand que moi tous
les postes ont baissé l on gagne là dès
leur retour parce qu'on est plus mobile
et parce qu'on va un peu plus vite aussi
une question commune à tous on a
beaucoup parlé de psychologie peut-être
qu'on y reviendra pour la dernière mais
il ya quand même un tri qui peut se
faire
guillaume en parlais tout à l'heure avec
des stats et alors pas peut-être pas des
stats brut il ya aussi des stades
avancés ce genre de choses est ce que
vous pouvez me parler chacun d'eux une
stat en particulier qui vous importe
pour tel type de joueur je sais que ça
va paraître très nicher et petite
lorgnette mais ça va nous permettre
aussi de discuter de l'importance de tel
ou tel aspect du jeu pour tel ou tel
poste
julien je puisse commencer par une
petite une petite phrase un peu old
school puisque d'edmond vais de mon père
donc c'était une autre époque en termes
de de scouting est trahie mais je la
regarde toujours cette stat ses
victoires défaites ça c'est ça la star
est assez vrai est donc celle là ben oui
c'est pas une stat avancée est assez
facile à trouver mais il faut pas
l'oublier
donc ça va dire pour tous les joueurs on
la regarde ça veut pas dire que 15
joueurs des équipes faibles ou voilà
mais c'est que on peut regarder les
contextes derrière victoires défaites il
ya surperformance à sous-performance de
collective et ça c'est un point qui
ajoute toujours au dossier
non après typiquement l'an le grand
classique et je pense qu'on va tous se
retrouver c'est qu'à un moment donné il
ya le tir à trois points qui est une
vraie variable noël et noël est très
importante sur le poste 4 et des très
importants aussi sur le poste 1 dans la
mesure où notamment ces dernières années
on a un titulaire dont ce n'est pas la
première force même s'il est capable
d'en mettre et donc donc on en cherche
et notamment cette année on on a eu des
réflexions autour de ça parce que ben
parce que parce que le jeu au delà de
l'adresse et du fait que ça rapporte
trois points de marquez un tir derrière
la ligne c'est très bien mais le space
in gay quelque chose d'absolument majeur
donc le pourcentage à trois points est
important mais pas seulement
faut pas se contenter du pourcentage je
pense que que nicolas guillaume romain
évidemment ne se font pas piéger mais
facilement des agents des observateurs
peuvent se faire avoir par le
pourcentage
le volume est aussi important que le
pourcentage certains modes amenant le
jeu qui est un pourcentage à 36 mais qui
en prend 1,6 par match je préfère
presque qui soit 33 et qu'ils en
prennent quatre si on recherche
quelqu'un qui soit une menace der la
vigne donc c'est c'est vraiment le
aujourd'hui c'est une stat qu'on peut
pas louper et j'en rajouterai une autre
en lancers francs lancé france c'est
pareil ça parle ça sente très simple
mais il ya tellement c'est un tel
handicap pour une équipe d'être peu
efficace aux lancers francs que c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas négliger
nous on a joué
justement contre vichy c'est au week end
on savait pertinemment que c'est une
équipe qui est très efficace aux lancers
francs
et forcément ça ça joue dans
l'appréhension du match c'est parfait tu
as cité les trois têtes communément
admise pour la projection du tir
pourcentage à 3 points volume à trois
points et réussi tôt aux lancers francs
qui sont toutes les trois importance
variable il ya des gens qui essayent de
faire des modèles mathématiques pour
pour pour essayer de l'évaluer métal est
très bien de rappeler que c'est pas
seulement en pourcentage à 3 points qui
va faire un bon shooteur évidemment
guillaume oui sur cette même question
bat sur les postes clés un petit peu ce
cette idée de l'adresse générale sur le
club 180 kw avec adresse 3.2.1 lancers
francs seillier de d'avoir d'avoir un
chiffre assez assez élevé là dessus et
par rapport aux meneurs de jeu
moi je suis sensible sur sur la
typologie des tirs à l'intérieur du
volume c'est-à-dire qu'on paye et attire
après pick and roll par exemple et
combien attire deux spots parce que là
aussi ça aussi c'est une variable assez
importante
si on cherche là aussi à écarter le
space in gay avoir des équipes en face
de nos qui peuvent par exemple
difficilement faire du protect sur le
pick and roll donc voila et puis
j'essaie toujours d'avoir deux ou trois
joueurs assez fort dans le pick and roll
nommé construction d' équipe pour avoir
de la création autour de ça et pour
qu'ils puissent créer du jeu autour de
ça il ya besoin qu'il ya un corps et
l'air de tir imputant et la deuxième
statistique sur laquelle passent du
temps c'est le rebond et notamment sur
la une stat un peu plus avancés qui
maintenant est plus facile à trouver sur
le les prises de pourcentage de rebond
disponibles et j'y suis de plus en plus
sensible sur tous les postes de jeu et
moi je viens il évoquer notre adresse
aux lancers francs mais par exemple sur
l'équipe de bois une des
caractéristiques c'est le nombre de
rebonds de leur meneur de jeu qui joue
constamment le rebond offensif et qui
comme il son rebond offensif derrière
mettre de la pression tout terrain et ce
lien dans l'impact sur le jeu sur le
tempo
c'est quelque chose qui a beaucoup de
sens pour moi donc ça c'est quelque
chose que que j'observe et notamment
chez les arrières qui passent beaucoup
de ceux qui passent du temps sur le
terrain s'il ya peu ou pas de rebond ça
va être un signal qui peut faire que
quand on fait le le ranking des joueurs
on en a se passer 1 devant parce qu'on
se dit dans une mauvaise soirée
celui qui va toujours grappiller et
trouve toujours une manière d'exister
dans le match
il nous intéresse un peu plus parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de temps creux on va
dire dans le jeu de pro b au moins un ou
deux par mi temps et dans ces temps là
l'équipe qui s'en sort c'est souvent
celles qui arrivent à faire le dos rond
grâce à ses joueurs qui vont chercher
des interceptions qui provoque des
passages en force qui vont prendre des
rebonds qui sont sûrs c'est sur ces
statistiques un petit peu peut-être
secondaire au départ mais qui ont de
l'importance
pardon mais pour ma culture personnelle
et celle des gens qui écoutent le club
des 180 ctu additionne les trois
pourcentage et ça doit faire 180 ouais
c'est ça aussi je connais ses 187 50 40
90 ils sont pas c'est beaucoup ça ouais
ben c c est ce qu on va dire que c'est
un idéal au début au début on est sur un
au début on est sur un idéal
et puis après on va on va positionner
mais pas par exemple sur sur le joueur
américain qui venait d'une petite dictée
ce batman ben on est on est dans ce
critère là cette année à 2% près et pour
moi c'est ça voulait me dire que ok
peut-être que la densité physique en
estonie lettonie est peut-être un cran
en dessous mais vu ses volumes
d'adressent même s'il descend d'un cran
et qu'il arrive en cumulé à 160 on va
dire je pense qu'il arrivera à exister
même dans le tir dans notre championnat
qui peut être que physiquement et un peu
plus un peu plus compétitifs ou
intéressant nicolas pour finir est-ce
que tu regardes certaines statistiques
avec le plus d'intérêt que d'autres
oui je regarde les statistiques
maintenant la totalité des luttes et de
l'équipe que je vais construire contre
j'ai jeu pour voir même des mineurs qui
sont pas bonnes j'ai eu deux mineurs qui
sont pas bonnes a chuté les trois points
mais et qui sont très très effective
mais la forme standard il faut que pour
tous - l'équipe on a de bons shooteurs
twitter même s'il en est dans la
position traditionnelle
bien sûr je regarde les frites rose pour
le bo5
car avoir une passante que qu'il faut
pas rester dans le sur le terrain dans
les dernières minutes à se mettre un
grand problème au moins entre les deux
il faut qu'il peut pour retirer après on
a besoin au moins de deux chanteurs
vraiment des qualités dans l'équipe ça
dépeint pas au moins vous dire ça veut
dire au moins les quarts en face à des
qte et en statistiques et j'aime
beaucoup c'est lé plus ou moins qu'on a
à la fin de sa dernière box de l'époque
score ça c'est pour moi c'est très
éducatif pour moi c'est très éducatif
spécialement pour les les équipes à la
moitié moment auquel dijon de revoir
tout le monde avec beaucoup de plus mais
va c'est la vague expliqué l'impact de
les joueurs dans les jours de l'équipe
dans les moments qu'il a joué pourtant
ça c'est une statistique très
intéressant très intéressant également
merci beaucoup à tous c'est ce que je
voulais c'est en carte blanche
est ce que mes questions évidemment sont
loin d'être parfaites est ce qu'on a
oublié d'aborder quelque chose qui vous
tenait à coeur du côté du recrutement du
recrutement par nom de l'évaluation du
talent allez je sais pas qui s'il y en a
un qui veut prendre la parole parmi vous
j'aime je peux dire quelque chose j'aime
beaucoup que nous avons parlé des valoir
les letta l'un d'eux les joueurs
m à la fin nous n'avons pas parlé de
l'état lente car nous avons je pense
nous avons découvre et qu'on a beaucoup
beaucoup d autres choses que nous
regardons à notre juste le talent le
talon est difficile à palper mais facile
à obtenir
roman est ce que tu es ce que tu voulais
ajouter quelque chose je n'ai pas voulu
non pardon mais je sais pas je suis là
je suis là on dire je suis là je fais du
featuring aujourd'hui je suis là je suis
à sonder talent je suis dans le décor
jeu je passe je passais j'observe voilà
lil wayne eminem ça beaucoup de
featurings guillaume julien des mots il
a donné un nombre juste juste dire que
c'est toujours très plaisant de parler
de basket
on avait parlé de 50 minutes on a bien
dépassé je pense que ça pourrait durer
encore longtemps donc ravis d'avoir pu
écouter nicolas que je ne connaissais
pas donc merci de cette invitation
non juste dire que on a un réservoir en
france on a parlé du réservoir us qui
est extraordinaire mais nous puisqu'on
parle de pro b je pense que ça peut être
valable dans une certaine mesure pour la
jeep élites ont un réservoir en france
et je pense que dans le scouting il ya
le chemin qu'on propose aux joueurs qui
est une variable et ça c'est notre
responsabilité de tout le reste c'est ce
qu'on lui met dans les mains et ce
qu'ils arrivent à transformer le joueur
mais notre responsabilité c'est le
chemin qu'on propose à un joueur et
qu'ils puissent l'arpenter ou non et moi
j'ai tendance à croire qu'en france on a
beaucoup de monde qui est capable de le
faire tout autant qu'on consomme qu'on
se donne la peine de les accompagner à
un peu et
donc voilà c'est juste un petit mot sur
les jeunes joueurs français parce que
j'ai envie d'y croire beaucoup et puis
après banon beaucoup de plaisir à parler
avec vous un message positif merci
beaucoup et on souhaite évidemment tout
le meilleur à la dea blois pour sait pas
si on doit appeler c'est à la fin de
saison la suite de saison qu'on jouera
donc voilà ce qu'on jouera guillaume
merci beaucoup également sais pas si tu
as merci beaucoup
aussi pour l'opportunité de parler puis
d'apprendre de tout le monde
à chacune de leurs interventions j'ai
pris beaucoup de notes par exemple c'est
bon c'est mon dada de toujours prendre
des notes quand quand j'écoute ou quand
je participe et j'ai noté plein de
choses intéressantes et peut-être que le
l'idée c'est de partir de scénario idéal
qu'on construit durant toute l'année
et puis au final d'aller de plus en plus
vers une une
une situation réaliste à la à la fin de
notre dans notre construction d' équipe
et là dessus je rejoins je rejoins
julien sur le fait de julien et nicolas
sur le fait de dieu bas il faut rester
dans notre adn et surtout coller avec
fait de raconter une histoire d'avoir
d'avoir des gens qui s'intègre au projet
avec de la durée croire aux personnes
peut être encore plus qu aux basketteurs
et leur créer une vraie place à
l'intérieur et je pense que de plus en
plus on s'intéresse à l'homme dans sa
globalité plutôt que simplement aux
joueurs stricto sensu de ces 40 minutes
sur le terrain quand on a une vision de
plus en plus élargi parce que on attend
de plus en plus de choses de lui ça va
bien au delà du sport
avoir des valeurs les porter et faire
partager c'est clair merci beaucoup et
également beaucoup de réussite à vichy
clermont pour la saison de pro b et
enfin merci à toi nicolas d'avoir été
avec nous merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le
temps de discuter de basket
[Musique]
merci beaucoup et évidemment on souhaite
beaucoup de victoires à sig pour l'année
d'ici la dernière équipe française en
baisser alors si je peux me permettre
voilà juste en passant par là et bien
sûr évidemment
évidemment je te laisse faire ton
autopro bien sûr merci à tous à tous
ceux qui ont écouté on se retrouve dès
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
podcast on essaiera de vous proposer des
thématiques ont pas forcément d'aidé
scouting report comme on le fait
habituellement mais des thématiques
comme celle qu'on a abordé aujourd'hui
quand il ya des personnes qui savent de
quoi elles parlent c'est évidemment
toujours intéressant merci donc julien
guillaume nicolas romain et à bientôt
tout le monde sur envergure ou sur
envergure point ces eaux
ciao